so let's start with the story of the day  alireza he played 200 bullet games  against neroditsky last night until five  in the morning  what's going on there  i have no idea when i heard that i was  quite shocked i must say i know that  alireza is a huge online bullet player  and he played a lot before i didn't know  that he's so active even nowadays  um  well it seems like he probably played  more games than anybody else in the five  months of preparation maybe because  probably if he's doing it during the  candidates he was doing it other times  as well  well this is something that of course an  old timer like i am uh it's a shock  because it could never happen even to  play  blitz games with some friends maybe on  the free day it could be but  only in the very beginning of my career  usually i was doing a lot of blitz games  in the in my training sessions but  during the tournament and talking about  bullet blitz i mean that would be out of  the world